it is 5 25 new wednesday morning another
example of the nevada department of
transportation showing they are serious
about a new project
a website and a logo as ndot launches
the state route 160 and state route 159
corridor study
now just to make sure you know state
route 160 that's the main road between
las vegas and prom the director of
induct christina swallow as our valley
grows traffic continues to increase on
state route 160
primarily due to ongoing growth and
development along the corridor
especially within pahrump and southwest
las vegas and state route 159 that's
charleston heading west of town to red
rock canyon then around the spring
mountain ranch state park and the town
of blue diamond recreational activities
along state route 159 are also
increasing which means that we need to
look at how we move everyone
people in cars people on bikes and
people walking
safely to where they want to go
so starting monday ndot will be holding
four in-person public meetings to get
your input on the project four in the
afternoon seven in the evening so monday
they're going to be impromptu tuesday
will be done in blue diamond wednesday
they'll be here in las vegas thursday
down at mountains edge all this
information and the link to ndot's
website on eightnewsnow.com click
traffic then what's driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone something's driving you
crazy email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com